you said dannis had a gauntlet right yes
what they look anything like that
I made what he wanted a device capable
of harnessing the power of the students
fine I'll do it myself
oh hey everybody its charlie I've been
getting a lot of questions about the
fake gauntlet the real gauntlet what the
timeline is how it was that Odin got
this if Thanos didn't have his real
gauntlet made till a couple of weeks
before infinity war started so it sounds
more confusing that it is the writers of
infinity war gave their idea although I
think that there were a couple errors
that they made themselves there were a
couple of moments in their explainer
where it made it sound like they were
definitely guessing on a couple things
but it's actually a pretty easy timeline
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's also a new round
of the Infinity war blu-ray giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so the big
thing that the writers of infinity were
said is that what people were like what
about Ragnarok hella says that this
gauntlet is fake so where did we get
that from because that's been there
since the first Thor movie when Thor and
Loki were young children they say that
they think that Loki had the gauntlet
made when he was pretending to be Odin
Eitri himself actually gives you a
pretty good idea for how things work at
the Dwarven space Forge when Thor goes
to make storm breaker
so he says that he has a Kings weapon a
design that could wield the power of the
Bifrost a danos killing weapon we know
that the events of infinity war lasts
less than a couple of days so Thor goes
asking for storm breaker and they make
it immediately it happens really quickly
so you keep in mind that the dwarves
have been around for millennia they
probably have all those designs stored
so it's not like Thor went asking for
storm breaker and he said ok give me a
couple months I'll design the weapon you
come back I'll have it ready like it's
literally sitting there in the queue
they Forge it immediately and he's good
to go so same thing probably happened
with the Infinity Gauntlet way back when
Odin or Loki asked for replicas so I'll
talk about that in a second but they did
say that Thanos asked for the gauntlet
less than a couple weeks before the
beginning of infinity war because you
remember that there's a couple things
that predate infinity war like him going
to Xander to get the Power Stone the
entirety of the events of him collecting
the stones takes place over less than a
couple of weeks so remember when we pick
up on Thor ship here at the beginning of
the movie he's already been at this for
a while so what happens is is this
Avengers age of Ultron post-credit scene
where he pulls the gauntlet out and says
fine I'll do it myself
is it actually happening right after the
events of age of Ultron we can say now
because of his timetable and collecting
the gems that this happened a couple of
weeks before the beginning of the movie
so if you guys didn't know a lot of
questions about his armor too it's the
same metal as his gauntlet
it's a rooh metal armor there's not that
many things that are special about it
hooroo metal is what Thor's hammer and
Stormbreaker are made of it's just
really strong on the level of vibranium
so his armor is just really badass
strong armor but like the writers say
this fake gauntlet the hell are called
out during Ragnarok was obtained by Loki
while he was pretending to be Odin this
is the problem with their explainer
Helen knew that it was a fake
immediately meaning that she knew what a
real gauntlet was remember she's been in
prison for 1,500 years because we know
that Thor didn't know about her
existence because he wasn't born till
after she had been imprisoned by Odin so
if she knew about the Infinity Gauntlet
more than 1500 years ago that means that
the dwarves probably created the design
for it
millennia ago when Odin was still in his
very warlike phase conquering the nine
realms remember the way that hella
explains it is it's that more than 1,500
years ago some point in the timeline
they're conquering the nine realms what
happened is is they got to the dwarves
and they made a bargain we will let you
continue to operate as long as you
provide us with armor and weapons a less
stabby version of what Thanos did when
he came to get the gauntlet III said he
let them live if I made him what he
wanted so Odin goes to the dwarves and
says I'll let you continue to operate
making weapons and armor as long as you
supply us with all the things that we
need
while we're conquering the other nine
realms so when hella is explaining this
mural here you have to imagine that all
of their weapons and all their armor was
supplied by the dwarves that was
probably one of the first places that
they went if you're gonna conquer the
universe which was their original
mission before Odin stopped nine realms
you're gonna need the best weapons and
armor so what happened is they probably
went there and saw that there was a
design for such a special gauntlet but I
actually think the more logical
explainer for how Odin got the fake
gauntlet is
that when he went to the dorms to
conquer them installed the design he
wanted to get a replica to use it to
strike fear into the hearts of the
enemies that he was getting ready to
conquer as a deterrent because he didn't
have all the Infinity stones but if you
were crazy powerful already wielding the
odinforce and dwarven forged weapons and
then you pulled out the Infinity
Gauntlet people are much more likely to
believe that it's real because you
already seem so powerful so why wouldn't
it be real so he probably trotted that
around while he was conquering the nine
realms then when he was done he put it
on the Shelf so that the legend would
spread that his treasure vault contained
all these really dangerous artifacts
because like hella says most of the
stuff in here is fake if Odin's enemies
of the other nine realms learned that
all those artifacts were fake then they
would probably charge Asgard and we know
that Odin is famous for withholding the
truth so it makes sense that he wouldn't
tell anyone that his gauntlet was fake
years ago I kind of died not until I
fulfill my destiny and lay waste to your
home so I think that's the better
explainer for how he got it the dwarves
have many special designs that they
haven't made yet over the millennia so
that when people come asking for special
things they say oh we do have something
that fits the description of what you're
talking about
it's called storm breaker let's make it
right now so getting you to Avengers for
a lot of you have asked you know the
dwarves are still alive will Iron Man or
any of the heroes go to the dwarves to
try and get them to make another
gauntlet so that they can wield the
Infinity stones or are they going to
forge some special Ironman armor because
we have shuri that's great at designing
armored Iron Man seems pretty obsessed
with fixing the universe you can't do
that without the Infinity stones they're
gonna need another device that will
allow them to wield that much power at
the same time there's been a lot of
speculation about the plot of Avengers 4
I've already done a video about the
synopsis they've released most of the
speculations that I've seen is in how
they obtained the Infinity stones
there's lots of time-travel theories I
don't want to get too deep into that
because it's speculation just remember
that you can't wield all six Infinity
stones and fix the universe without a
device to channel that power
in there are a couple of ways that they
could accomplish that I'm really hoping
that they just modify Iron Man's armor
because Iron Man already wears armor
wouldn't it be bad asked to see him wear
a version of that with all the gems
embedded in it of course we probably
won't get a teaser for any of that stuff
until later this year I'm not expecting
any footage at Comic Con but I am
expecting some Captain Marvel so what
will probably happen is because the
writers of infinity war also said they
have no idea and do not care how Sony
markets spider-man 2 in the wake of
spider-man dying during infinity war
they basically said not our problem so
we'll probably get our first teaser for
Avengers 4 before the end of the year
around the same time that we start
getting spider-man trailers for that
next movie around the same time we also
get Captain Marvel but mostly be
expecting Captain Marvel so we'll be
talking about that more soon but leave
all your video requests in the comments
below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner tiny Rick please private message
me on the about page my channel so I can
get your contact details there actually
is new Rick and Morty season four that
I'm working on next so that should post
in a little while but click here for
that Stormbreaker scene and click here
for the new ant-man the wasp trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]